0-100 km/h
is the standard test
for how fast a car accelerates.
The Brits call it
"nought to sixty" mph.
An everyday road car
with a bit of power
can do that in
six or seven seconds.
A Formula One car, about two seconds.
As I record this, the fastest-accelerating
road-legal car in the world
is the Rimac Nevera,
which can go
from 0 to 100km/h
in 1.85 seconds.
This is "mythen", built by a team
from ETH Zurich, a Swiss university,
and it hits 100km/h
in under a second.
- This car is the current holder
of the world record in acceleration
from 0-100km/h
for electric vehicles.
For the world record project,
we brought together a team
of alumni and current team members,
some are students,
some are recent graduates.
We took a car that was fully designed
by students, we modified it.
That also allowed some of the members
that are still students
to do research and make a master thesis.
- And I'm about to get in it and do that.
But there is quite a history of
floppy-haired British presenters
getting into high-speed vehicles
and ending up in hospital,
so I've got a lot of safety
briefing to do first.
- To build a car that can go
this fast, you really need
to go down to the first
principles of physics.
You need to be able to put
enough force into the ground
in a very short amount of time.
Just pure grip reaches its limits
at around 1½ seconds, approximately.
To get more force into the ground,
we use a self-developed system,
which we call "power ground effect".
We suck the air out underneath the car
from a big plate,
and this pulls the car to the ground
to make the car accelerate faster.
We use two fans that power up
shortly before launch
to pull the car down,
to be able to create
that under-pressure.
However, for the back wheels,
we need more torque.
So for this, we developed
a new generation of motors
that has approximately
twice the amount of torque.
Each of the motors has
approximately the same power
as a small hatchback.
- Everything is custom, self-designed,
so it's quite expensive.
The main source of parts is from
our sponsors from the industry.
We also get a lot of
support from the university.
Our mission is not to build race cars,
it is to build up engineers.
- At world record pace,
a lightweight driver in here
pulls 3.8 Gs peak acceleration.
I'm going to add about
30 more kilos of weight,
so I'm not going to quite hit that pace,
but it's going to be close.
It's almost as fast as the catapult
that launches fighter jets
from aircraft carriers.
It's faster than any rollercoaster launch
apart from one in Japan
that's currently closed
because it kept shattering people's bones.
There are cars which take
off faster than "mythen" here,
but they're top fuel dragsters
running on nitromethane,
loud enough to cause hearing damage,
and not suitable for anything other
than going in
a straight line for a few seconds.
And yes, I will just be going in
a straight line for a few seconds
but in theory, I could go
round an actual racetrack.
- Electrically, the main danger
is high voltage.
There are emergency buttons.
Push that button to turn off the car.
If there is, for example,
a fire in the car,
the driver has to be
able to get out quickly.
It's something we have to train
just to be quick enough.
- That was 6.6.
- [sighs]
- You have to be able to exit
the car within five seconds.
- Go.
- Clear!
- 4.6.
- That'll do.
- It's absolutely difficult to describe
because it's only a second.
It's a really surreal experience
because you don't really
believe it just happened.
You go into acceleration mode,
roll to the start,
initiate power ground effect,
which will suck you to the floor.
- PG, active.
- Both fans active.
- Yeah.
- Oh boy. Okay.
- You will have to pull on the buttons
behind the steering wheel
and then push throttle.
And then when you release
there is a split second
where nothing happens
but then you will get launched.
- Flaps. Throttle.
[shouts]
Holy...!
What!
- After you have reached a hundred kmh,
the car will shut down.
- What?
- And then you can slowly go on the brakes.
That was the longest second
of my life. I...
Was that really only like
one and a bit seconds?
That felt like five.
- That was faster.
- That felt like five seconds.
- Pretty much dead on 1.4 seconds.
- 1.4? I mean, it's your
round of applause folks.
Congratulations. That's a heck of a thing.